well the health minister nadine doris
joins me now
good morning to you um after everything
doctors and nurses have done for us over
the
the last year the sacrifices they've
made
is a one percent pay increase enough
well of course we recognize the
sacrifice and the commitment
and vocation of nurses and all health
workers over the past year
we've all been touched by all personally
experienced by
help from nhs workers but i think it's
important to note that
the priority of the government has been
about protecting people's livelihoods
about continuing the furlough scheme
about fighting the pandemic and and
we've put
huge effort into that and we did not
want nurses to go
unrecognized or doctors and no other
public sector employee is receiving a
pay rise there has been a pay freeze
but the one percent offer is the most we
think we can afford which we have put
forward
to the pay review body that will be um
discussed that we will wait for feedback
from unions and other
health sector um stakeholders and
and see where we move to on this but the
one percent is what the government can
afford
it's what the offer is and you know it
would be wrong to say
that a single person in the government
does not appreciate the effort of nurses
we absolutely do
but you you've been a nurse yourself i
mean what we're talking about here is an
extra three pound fifty
take home um for experienced nurses a
week
that that isn't enough what they're
saying to us is it it seems like an
insult
well as john's report said before i came
on
nurses have had a 12 increase in pay
over the last three years the average
nurse's salary is around quite rightly
34 000 per annum but i'm afraid at this
moment in time
at the tail end of a pandemic and at
this time last year we were just looking
in the face of this global pandemic
and we all know what the last year has
held and what we had to go through
and that has been a huge amount of
expense
on on fighting the pandemic and keeping
to our best
possible way as a result of the efforts
of nhs staff people safe
keeping people safe was our priority now
protecting livelihoods
and and people's futures jobs businesses
making sure people can stay employment
extending the further scheme
those have to be our priorities now it
has to be about protecting people
and livelihoods now that we've saved
lives
hand on heart can you look at nhs
workers in the face and say
you know you you are not our priority at
this moment in time because that seems
to be what you're saying
no because that's not true as i said no
other public sector employee
is receiving any pay rise there has been
a pay freeze
the nhs workers are going to receive a
pay rise but as i said there are still
changes going as your report said
there are still pay uplifts coming
through from the agenda for change
nurses have received a 12 pay rise over
the last year and quite rightly so
and and their salary is now an average
of 34 000 pounds a year
we wanted to personally as a health
minister
and as a previously you were a nurse
would you like to see them
get more than one percent in an ideal
world is that what you would like to see
everybody in an ideal world would love
to see nurses paid
far more in an ideal world but we are
coming out of a pandemic
where we have seen huge borrowing and
cost to the government
you know only a year ago this week when
we had really no idea what was
coming at us and you know we've come
through this as a
as a country with a huge effort
from both nurses and doctors and all
healthcare workers
we have come through we're coming out
the end of this pandemic now
and the priority has to be about saving
people's jobs
which is why the furlough scheme has
been extended until the autumn
is this something that that would have
been imposed by the the treasury would
there have been disagreements between
the treasury and the department of
health
uh that's way above my pay scale i have
no idea of any disagreements or any
discussions
i know what we can afford though i know
what we've spent we all know what we've
spent and everyone knows
the efforts that the chancellor has put
in to make sure
and to ensure this government protects
people's jobs
all the way through this pandemic and
continuing now until the future
until we know we're well and truly out
of the other side
the calling thing for many uh in the nhs
is in real terms
this is actually a pay cut if inflation
uh is uh predicted to rise as has been
suggested
well even john ashworth said um in your
report if the predictions come true we
don't know
what the future holds we know that at
the moment you know we spent
10 years following a labor government
fixing the economy
what we need to do now is to make sure
we keep fixing the hole in that roof
to keep a stable enough an economy
stable moving forward
and the only way we can keep the economy
stable is to protect people's jobs
so that they have jobs to go back to to
protect businesses so they're there to
offer employment in the future
and that's where our priority has to be
you know it's like
anyone in any home you have a priority
on your purse
and our priority is about keeping people
in work
and protecting people's jobs that's the
choice we've had to make moving forward
and you know as i said again no other
public sector employee
is receiving any pay offer over the next
year
this is a recommendation from the
government which has gone to the public
at the pay review board that has gone
forward as a recommendation
we it would there was an offer made
to there has been an offer made to the
pay review board we hope
that that will be accepted because it's
what the government can afford
if the um pay review board comes back
and says actually that this is derisory
um and enforces that on the government
that they actually have to increase the
the the pay offered to nhs staff is that
something you would would welcome well
they are discussions for the future and
the discussions that the
uh the hancock uh the secretary of state
and the treasury and others will
have as i say at this moment in time our
priority is protecting jobs it's about
extending the furlough and
it's about make ensuring that we made an
offer
to the nhs because you know they the
huge effort
is that there are not words to express
how grateful
everyone has been to now they don't feel
that those in the nhs
don't feel as if that the government is
grateful
by any stretch of the imagination we all
remember the the clap for the nhs
going out and seeing shots of rishi
sunak and
boris johnson clapping hands for the nhs
this morning
they're saying that it doesn't feel as
though their efforts have been
welcomed and have been received and
certainly not reflected in this one
percent
pay increase that's being proposed well
i hope nurses recognize that it's this
government
which has given them the 12 increase
over the past three years in their pay
and that we have acknowledged their
their effort and their contribution
by making a recommendation to the pay
review body this time
um as i said quite rightly the average
nurse pay is now at 34 000 pounds per
annum that's happened under this
government
and and we're proud of that and and
quite rightly nurses you know they're we
owe so much to them but at this moment
in time having faced the year that we
have with this pandemic
i think some have described you know the
but can you understand though
why sorry to interrupt but i just want
to get to the crux of this really can
you
understand why they are so disappointed
this morning
yes of course i can understand anyone
can understand
but i want every nurse and every doctor
to know we are
hugely grateful to you but that the
government has
to make set priorities and our
priorities have had to be
saving people's jobs extending furlough
offering business grants so that
businesses can keep running about
keeping people
in employment so that you know without a
good economy without those businesses
without people in employment
we need that money to continue funding
our nhs
our world-class nhs and so that had to
be the government's priority
you've obviously explained the the
government's importance that they they
hold the
uh nhs in high regard but the institute
of fiscal studies
um they criticized the budget for having
implausibly low spending plans including
excuse me a 30 billion pound reduction
in health care budgets
next year now i'm wondering why you
would think that public spending
should be lower than it was a year ago
pre-covered
well that's absolutely not true and
um i think there's that that was uh
disabused yesterday
that 30 um billion i believe was
a reduction on the pandemic spending
it's not there is
there are actually real time increases
going into the
nhs budget year on year that figure i'm
afraid is completely wrong
that's not on our annual funding of the
nhs
that was on our pandemic budget which is
completely separate
but uh this size correct me if i'm wrong
on these figures three billion has been
allocated to bringing
waiting lists down in uh 2021 to 22.
that's one of the areas that you've
injected cash into but
1.3 billion has been spent by hospitals
on
adapting to the virus so when you put
them side by side
you can see that the the shortfall
there are absolutely no cuts moving
forward
to front frontline nhs services either
in
um waiting this accidents and accident
and emergency
um there's just no cuts moving forward
there are
real-time increases going into the nhs
budget
so i'm afraid that isn't right there are
no cuts to nhs budgets
moving forward we have obviously
allocated huge amounts of money to
dealing with the pandemic which was
required
obviously as we get on top of pandemic
as the vaccine rollout continues
then we're not going to need as much
money to to fight the virus
in the way that we have done over the
past year and there were i believe you
will see the reductions but in terms of
the real-time nhs budget
there are no reductions